MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
In this short
section, you're going
to look at the weak
interaction a little bit more,
and specifically discuss
neutral currents.
We looked in some detail
at charged currents--
specifically, the
interaction with quarks.
So here, I'm going to look
at the Z boson specifically,
and the weak interaction
via the neutral current.
So studying those
two processes here,
where there is an
electron and a positron
through some process including
a Z boson and a photon
and resulting in a
muon and an anti-muon--
those processes have been
studied in great detail
at SLAC and at CERN, at the SLC,
and the Large Electron-Positron
Collider.
So if we want to calculate
the cross-section
and study the cross-section
of the center of mass energy,
we see a number of
interesting effects.
At low energies, and
at very large energies,
the cross-section runs with
1 over the energy squared.
But at the mass of the Z boson,
we see this enormous resonance
here.
The cross-section at the
resonance from the Z boson
is about 200 times that
of just a photon exchange.
So this allows you to study the
Z boson with great precision
at those colliders.
You have sizable
cross-section when you are
in electron-positron colliders.
And then you can,
with precision,
look at, what is the rate
into a muon/anti-muon?
What is the rate into
a quark/anti-quark?
And so on.
And you can study the mass,
the width of the Z boson
with an enormous
level of precision.
Again, so I will not go
into too much detail here.
And please have a look at
chapter 9.6 in Griffiths,
for example.
But there's many other resources
where you can learn more
about [? neutral ?] currents.
Neutral currents,
electroweak neutral currents
are specifically important
in the study of neutrinos,
as we will discuss more
in the lectures as well.